bit of breaking news we can bring you
about covert 19. a major breakthrough
has been announced in the development of
the vaccine for coronavirus
we've cleared one significant hurdle but
there are several more to go
before we know the vaccine can be used
it's exceeded scientists expectations
and its discovery has been hailed as a
great day for science and humanity
but will the fisa vaccine put an end to
the coronavirus crisis
almost 1.3 million people have died
during the covid19 pandemic but now
we could be closer to a solution this
vaccine is one of around 12 worldwide in
the final stages of testing
but it is the first to produce any
results
it's being developed by the german
biotech company
biontech and the american pharmaceutical
giant
pfizer and has been found to be 90
percent effective
in preventing people from getting kovid
19.
so how do we get here well phase three
of pfizer's clinical trials involved
more than 43
000 volunteers from six countries the
volunteers were given two doses of
either the vaccine
currently neatly code named as bnt-162b2
or a placebo after their second dose
ninety percent of participants given the
vaccine were found to be protected from
covet 19.
pfizer was able to calculate this by
comparing the number of covered cases in
the two groups
only 94 people had contracted the virus
if the results are as good in high-risk
elderly patients
and we don't know that for sure until
the company has done more analysis
it would mean the vaccine would prevent
90 percent of hospital admissions
and deaths this is huge for the two
companies and the news has seen stock
markets surge
the ftse 100 jumped by 5.5 when it was
announced
and pfizer's own shares have let by 14
now pfizer and biontech want to apply
for emergency approval so they can use
the vaccine by the end of november
but caution is needed we absolutely
cannot
rely on this news as a solution
and the biggest mistake we could make
now
would be to slacken our resolve
at a critical moment not everyone in the
scientific world
is convinced the trials haven't been
going for long enough
to tell whether the protection will fade
or by
how much the way i feel is this this is
really good news but we have to um
manage expectations for my taste it you
know
it might take the whole of 2021 if not
more
to really get levels of vaccine-induced
herd immunity
so it's for a long time it's going to go
hand-in-hand with all the measures that
we have at the moment
we also don't know whether the vaccine
will stop the virus from transmitting
if it doesn't then we will still be
living with the virus for a long time to
come
that means social distancing and face
masks
pfizer and bion tech also need to prove
that they can make the vaccine
at scale because we will need billions
of doses of it
the companies say they can supply 50
million doses by the end of 2020
and 1.3 billion by the end of the
following year
but manufacturing enough doses and then
immunizing hundreds of millions of
people around the world
is a monumental challenge earlier this
year the
uk government ordered 40 million doses
of the pfizer vaccine enough for about a
third of the population
since you need two doses each the uk
government has managed to secure a deal
for 40 million doses
priority will be given to hospital and
care home staff
and those most at risk it's still too
early to judge this new vaccine but the
hope is
it'll be a game changer
you